big crowds and loud noises make it as
especially hard for children with autism
to go through airports and fly on
airplanes so major airplanes have found
a unique way to help Kris Van Cleave
shows us how the effort is really
starting to take off for six year old
Nathan Diamond today is a big day he'll
be walking on an airplane for the first
time since he was a baby
he has autism so he's sensitive to the
noise and activity of an airport and
changes to his routine can be disruptive
they don't travel often but when his
parents Sonia and Jonathan take him to
visit family they make an eight-hour
drive to Arkansas they could fly in
about 90 minutes how's it going so far
it was it was a little nerve-wracking I
think for us but for him he was taking
the challenge um once a month Delta
offers a special orientation program for
families touched by autism to help get
kids comfortable with the airport
process from check-in and security to
boarding and what to expect on the plane
the easiest thing for us was like who we
sit down we own this plane but this is
the hardest part for him sitting down
these narrow ways and you see that's the
hardest part for him one in 59 8 year
olds is on the autism spectrum
among them captain Eric Reese his son
he's led the Atlanta tours for the last
four years and you worry about your
child and when you've seen a child
having a meltdown that's on the spectrum
it's scary and these families are scared
to death that it's gonna happen on a
plane and they're we're gonna land and
we're gonna create all sorts of problems
and disrupt the passengers and things
like that but I'm sure them that's not
the case Delta offers these tours at its
Atlanta and Minneapolis hubs other
airlines including Alaska American and
JetBlue offers similar programs at
airports across the country for young
kids with autism these new sensory
experiences the overhead page all of the
sights and sounds can be quite
overwhelming and as a result many people
with autism really need to have
experiences before they get to the
airport just to prepare them for that
Delta built this special sensory room in
Atlanta's international terminal as a
place families can go to calm down if
the airport becomes sensory overload
it's a first for Delta what's it like
for you will see and seeing the
reactions from the kids when
particularly when they're their eyes
light up
it's just amazing and that it's doing
good and it's making families feel
empowered and confident and comfortable
and I want them to have the same
experiences with their children that
I've had with mine and the diamonds are
ready they just have to agree on where
to go I mean my person was Paris I know
it we want to do fairs thanks he's suave
isn't he like I've seen the captain seat
whatever the final destination from the
looks of Nathan in the cockpit he's
about ready for takeoff
for CBS this morning Kris Van Cleave
Atlanta
you